remember toolbars back in the late '90s
and early 2000s toolbars were basically
synonymous with the address bar of
Internet Explorer you had tool barss for
searching tool bars for shortcuts tool
bars for torren and of course tool barss
that you accidentally installed as
bloatware some people's browsers no joke
looked just like this but that's not too
surprising given that basically every
major tech company had their own set of
toolbars from mson messenger and Yahoo
to AOL and ask.com and they all seemed
somewhat useful but likely the most
recognizable toolbar of all time is none
other than the Google Toolbar in fact I
would argue that the Google Toolbar was
one of the main products that initially
put Google on the map if you're on the
younger side you may have never seen the
internet before Chrome but the truth is
that Chrome was actually a rather late
entry into the browser space having not
come out till late 2008 up until this
point the only way to easily access
Google was to either install the toolbar
or type in google.com into the address
bar something that I would hope that we
all know is a sin so most people
resorted to the former fun fact suer
pitch's first job at Google was actually
to lead product management for the
Google Toolbar back in 2004 but since
then toolbars have largely fallen out of
favor to be honest I can't remember the
last time I saw someone with even a
single toolbar and taking a look at
Google Trends this seems to be the
overarching trend browser tool bars have
been on a downward spiral for nearly 20
years now in fact Google themselves
killed off their toolbar at the end of
2021 so it seems that the era of browser
toolbars is very much over but why it
seems that having quick access to the
most popular services that you use right
underneath the address bar would be
rather convenient well it turns out that
the answer actually has a lot more to do
with maximizing control Power and
influence over the web as opposed to
some sort of logical reason so join me
as we take a look back at what really
happened to
toolbars to bars obviously got left
behind and the sad reality is that
everyday people are also getting left
behind High interest rates have made it
much harder to afford cars and homes
while high inflation has been eating
away at the savings that that people do
still have we wanted to challenge this
reality and help everyday investors
thrive in the modern High interest rate
environment and that's why we created
Silo a modern Bond investing platform
with Silo you can invest in government
and corporate bills and bonds and earn
historically high yields of 4 to 7% this
is where all of the biggest companies
and investors have been Sheltering their
cash for decades and it seems that
leveraging this opportunity is now more
important than than ever so if you'd
like to do that yourself with the
protection of $500,000 in sipc insurance
and $2.5 million on FDIC Insurance
please consider checking out Silo in the
description below but anyway taking a
look back the story of toolbars dates
back to the early 1990s well before the
internet or browsers became mainstream
toolbars which were originally called
ribbons were actually largely
popularized by Microsoft who introduce
them into the office suite these ribbons
were almost immediately a hit as made
the software far more useful and
accessible and as you know these ribbons
are still around to this day and are
very much a critical part of any office
product but while office ribbons took
off quite early on it took a lot longer
for browser toolbars to even make their
debut largely because browsers weren't
really even a thing yet of course you
had the worldwide web browser that came
out in 1990 but it wasn't until Mosaic
and more notably Netscape that browsers
really started gaining mainstream
popularity and this trend was simply put
into overdrive in 1995 when Microsoft
launched Internet Explorer and started
bundling it in with Windows but while
browsers were gaining momentum they were
still quite rudimentary here is a mosaic
looked for example it could only display
static content and functionality was
largely limited by what the browser
developers were able to pack in as such
it was only a matter of time until we
saw the world of browser extensibility
begin to evolve starting with plugins
this of course starts with the infamous
Adobe Flash Player 1996 and Java 1998
these two revolutionized the browsing
experience as they open the door for
everything from Dynamic websites and
video streaming to browser games and
more intense Enterprise applications and
as people started getting used to more
capable browsers they naturally wanted
to do more and more leading us into the
era of browser toolbars in the late '90s
and early 2000s we saw the first
thirdparty toolbars pop up but unlike
the the office ribbons these didn't
exactly blow up in popularity in fact it
was quite the opposite until a special
someone stepped into the field Google
despite eventually becoming the world's
largest internet company Google didn't
start off with the grand Ambitions in
fact it wasn't even originally called
Google it was actually called backrub
and backrub started off as an academic
research paper that was more focused on
the theoretical side of how to organize
and rank so much data fortunately the
name backrub didn't stick around for
long but Google did stay an academic
project in fact it was actually
originally launched on Stanford's
network with the domain google.
stanford.edu in 1996 and it was until 2
years later that Google was turned into
a company but even this wasn't too
serious the founders were actually
willing to sell all of Google for just
$1 million in 1999 but the buyers passed
on the deal after this deal fell through
though everything changed Google was no
longer just a College project with a
generous exit it was a serious company
that needed to maximize users and
revenue but the reality was that Google
was competing in a rather saturated
space all of the biggest companies
including AOL Microsoft and Yahoo wanted
to control their search space and sure
Google might have had higher quality
search results but this only mattered if
people even tried it out what Google
needed was a new way to put their search
engine in front of people enter the
Google toolbar
the Google Toolbar made its debut on
December 11th 2000 with one simple goal
make highquality search results easier
to access than ever at first the toolbar
was basically just a search bar that
allowed you to easily search Google from
any website but over the years the
toolbar became much more than just that
for example after the launch of Gmail
users could link the tool toolbar with
their email and load saved bookmarks and
history Google also introduced features
such as translation autofill and spell
checking into the toolbar all of these
features made the Google Toolbar quite
useful but its usefulness itself wasn't
what drove its popularity one of the
main ways that Google made a toolbar
popular was by making it bloatware I'm
not even kidding Google partnered with a
bunch of already popular software
companies and struck deals to bundle in
the toolbar with their software for
example simple they had such deals with
real player and even Sun Micro Systems
but anyway as the Google Toolbar started
to gain popularity the big boys
naturally stepped into the arena as well
in 2004 Microsoft launched an MSN
toolbar AOL launched a toolbar and Yahoo
even launched a toar for Firefox and all
of these were rather popular in fact to
bars accounted for 12% of search queries
on Google 18% at Yahoo and a whopping
42% at ask and that that's just the
search queries that were directly being
made through these toolbars who knows
how many people these tool bars actually
drove to each of these Services it
wasn't just these Giants that were
launching toolbars either every internet
company that you can think of suddenly
had a toolbar the one that stuck out to
me most was from Amazon actually before
Alexa became the voice of Amazon Amazon
actually had a toolbar called Alexa but
as you would guess not all toolbars were
quite as benign or as helpful as Alexa
which leads us into likely the biggest
Pitfall of toolbars their perception
throughout the 2000s toolbars quickly
built up an association with malware
spyware and bloat wear many of the
toolbars that you ended up with weren't
even intentional you were just trying to
download wiir or uTorrent and all of a
sudden the next time you open your
browser you're met with a horrendous
blob at the top ironically Google was
very much part of the problem but they
weren't too concerned about that because
they were starting to sense a much
bigger problem you see Google was
starting to become a bit too successful
in 2004 they would IPO and just one year
later they would reach a market cap of
$100 billion and this success started to
make the big players rather nervous
Google was no longer the scrappy startup
with the popular search engine and
toolbar they had a slew of products
including YouTube Gmail and Android and
with a market cap of hundred billion do
they were very much a big tech company
that was eating into the market share of
Hotmail Yahoo and MSN and the worst part
about all of this for Microsoft was that
they weren't just standing by and
watching it happen they were literally
enabling it after all it was internet
explor generous toolbar compatibility
that had made the Google Toolbar so
popular in the first place as such it
was time for Microsoft to put their own
products first and block out leaches
like Google and with that they did
absolutely nothing the reality was that
while it was likely that Microsoft felt
somewhat threatened by Google's Rising
dominance they never actually did
anything about it Google on the other
hand
did in 2006 Su pit the leader of Google
Tobar would make the Bold claim that
Microsoft could change Internet Explorer
at any time and threaten Google's
toolbar business and his solution to
this concern was for Google to create
their own browser and to challenge
Microsoft before Microsoft pulled the
rug was he actually concerned about
Microsoft pulling the rug or did he just
use this fear as a way to sell Chrome to
be honest it was probably more of the
latter you see Sunder had already
pitched the idea of chrome before but
his idea was rejected due to cost
concerns so it seems that Sunder
cleverly used the Microsoft threat to
frame Chrome as a defensive move as
opposed to an offensive move and it
worked Chrome would be green lit with
Slender at the helm and two years later
we would see the launch of Chrome on
September 2nd 2008 from the very
beginning the intention of chrome was
pretty clear cut out competitors and
grow power for Google but to their
credit they did frame this really well
instead of saying that Chrome wouldn't
support any toolbars they pitched Chrome
as a super clean Bowser that wasn't
bogged down by a bunch of extensions
now I do want to note that Chrome didn't
support their own toolbar either but
this isn't really a sacrifice after all
with chrome Google had control over the
entire browser despite this clear
ulterior motive though most people
didn't really care they were fed up with
the toolbars being bloatware and
Internet Explorer in general so when
Google came out with a clean browser it
didn't take long for people to switch
over and for Chrome to become the
dominant browser Chrome did eventually
come out with their own store for
thirdparty extensions called the Chrome
web store but they made sure to
differentiate it from toolbar such that
no extension would really be a threat to
Google search and that was really the
end of it with chrome dropping support
for traditional toolbars and chrome
becoming the dominant browser toolbars
quickly became a relic of the past if
anything most users were happy to move
away from toolbars as they very much
remembered the nightmares of this so
toar went down as just something that
naturally went obsolete with evolving
technology but the reality was that it
wasn't all that natural it was Google
that made toe bars popular in the first
place and it was also Google that
eventually killed toar with the launch
of chrome and that's what really
happened to toolbars something else that
has become a relic of the past is
uTorrent check out this video to learn
more but until then I'm Hari and I'll
see you guys on the next one
[Music]